Go ahead and get started because we have three talks today, and so I want
to make sure we can get through it and make sure that there's time for
questions.
Oh, yeah.
I'm Rula Tamimi. I'm a cancer epidemiologist, and I'm at Weill
Cornell Medicine in New York City.
So in terms of our format, I'm just going to give five minutes of intro to
the session, then I'm going to turn it over to David Wetter, who
is at the University of Utah in the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
He's going to talk about community-engaged research partnerships.
Then I will talk about some of the work that's being done at my center on
social capital.
And then Melissa Bondy from Stanford University is going to talk about
targeting very upstream
factors in relationship to
poverty and its relationship with cancer mortality.
And then we'll have time for a panel discussion at the end.
So just to make sure that we're all talking about the same thing, I just wanted to
share what the definition that we are using with respect to persistent poverty.
So the US Department of Agriculture defines persistent poverty
as census tracts where more than 20% of the population is
underneath the federal poverty line and has been in that condition
for 30 plus years. And so throughout these
presentations, when we talk about persistent poverty areas, that's what
we are talking about.
And there are many characteristics that we see in persistent poverty areas
that are associated with cancer and cancer mortality.
So many of these areas may have structural factors, different
demographic factors or environmental factors, and you'll hear about some of those
today.
They also tend to have limited access to healthcare,
prevalence differences with respect to risk factors for cancer that can
also contribute to poor mortality,
and we have evidence of higher cancer incidence rates as well as higher
mortality rates from cancer in these areas that are characterized as
persistent poverty areas.
Some of the initial work that really stimulated additional research in
this area was published by colleagues at the National Cancer
Institute, including Shoba Srinivasan and Bob
Croyle, that really showed that there are a number of cancer sites when you look
at people living in persistent poverty areas versus
non-persistent poverty areas, that there are higher
levels of cancer mortality. And so you can see those different cancer
sites for which this is true.
So we know that persistent poverty is a significant determinant of
cancer outcomes. We also know that the majority of cancer
prevention opportunities are really focused more at the individual
level. And this initiative that came from the National Cancer
Institute really put out a charge to shift
towards thinking about the causes of the causes and really charged
people with thinking about how to intervene upstream, really on more
social, economic drivers that may influence
cancer outcomes. And so as part of that,
a number of centers put in applications to really try and study
these interventions that would target structural and institutional factors.
There were five
NCI-funded centers across the United States. You can see them here.
These are the names of those five centers.
So the three of us on this panel represent the top three
centers. There are two others that are not represented here today.
I just wanted to make sure that they are represented.
So those are the Be Well Acres Homes from MD Anderson and the
CARE Center at the University of Alabama in Birmingham.
I think many people here are probably familiar with the Warnecke Model.
Our PPI, this Persistent Poverty Initiative network, came
together to really try and put together a framework to describe how persistent
poverty can impact cancer burden.
And this is really built on top of the Warnecke Model
and really highlights some of the many different levels that can
contribute to cancer disparities.
Our PPI initiative is laid on here so you can
see what some of the targeted interventions are from
this,
focusing on different factors in terms of education,
built environment, income supplementation, and you're going to hear about some of
these today.
And really, you can see at the bottom of this is community-engaged
participation. And so as part of our panel today,
David Wetter is really going to talk about community engagement to kick us off.
I'm going to talk about the work at our center, which is focused more on the
institutional context in this box.
And then Melissa Bondy is going to talk about even further upstream, some of the
social policies that can influence cancer
outcomes.
And so with that, I will turn it over to David Wetter.
Good morning.
I'm going to talk a little bit about how do you
reach out to and work with both populations living in
poverty and geographic areas that are characterized by persistent
poverty. And there's lots of new engagement models that are
coming out, and I'm going to be a little bit blasphemous
because I actually think it's pretty simple to do this.
And I'm going to tell you how we do it, and it's
something that's worked very well.
It's a very simple, very common sense framework.
So,
the Center for HOPE, which is where our center is located,
both there and at Montana
State University, is we bring communities and researchers together to create
long-term solutions to improve the health of the broader
population.And
as you can see from that picture on the right, there's lots of places
where that can go wrong. One of the places is with the
community engagement piece.
So first of all is identifying
where
populations living in persistent poverty and geographic areas
characterized by persistent poverty are located and who serves
them. So federally qualified health centers, many of you
probably have heard of them. We call them community health centers in Utah because
that's what they prefer. There are 14 systems in
Utah shown all around that
diagram. And then they're served by the Association for
Utah Community Health or AUCH.
Come on, there we go. Usually that gets a smile. Come on.
That's a pretty cool name.
They are the federally designated primary care association,
and they provide technical assistance and training, et cetera, to all the
community health centers around the state.
So FQHCs, or I'm going to keep using the term CHCs,
are phenomenal places to reach these kind of folks because
they provide care regardless of their ability to pay.
In Utah, there's 14 systems, over 60 primary care clinics.
They care for about 140,000 patients, which is down about
25,000 patients, which
you might be able to guess some of the reasons for that. It's very unfortunate.
But the demographics are also very different than what
I know you all are thinking about when you think of Utah.
Because we've got 52% of their patients live below the federal
poverty line, over half are Latino,
almost half are best served in a language other than English,
and 45% are uninsured. And I want to highlight that
45% uninsured because nationally, the rate of
uninsurance at FQHCs is 19%. In
Utah, it's 45. What that means is our
CHCs have to do a heck of a lot with
very, very few financial resources.
So they're actually mind-bogglingly impressive when
you get the chance to work with them on how they're doing amazing
work, unbelievably dedicated, passionate people with not very
much money.
So that's who we partner with. And here's our model.
Again, very, very simple. And all I want to do is
highlight a few of the key partnership characteristics, a few of the key
engagement activities, and some of the things we've learned in working
with them
over about the last nine and a half years.
I came to Utah and Huntsman Cancer
Institute nine and a half years ago.
So first of all,
this is actually the key thing. It's actually the very
simple thing.
Folks will partner with you if you address their
priorities. Academics are not very good at that.
We often want to push what we want to study onto the
partners. And surprisingly,
they don't want to partner with you.
It's actually really, really easy if you
address their priorities. And if you think about it,
if all of you are writing a grant and you really need statistical support
and you ask me for help, I'm a behavioral scientist, can't balance a
checkbook. And I go, "Well, I can't provide statistical
support, but I can teach you all about behavior change.
Let's do behavior change." You're going to go, "No, I need statistical support."
You ain't going to partner with me.
So this is the number one key thing.
And then the other thing is share.
This is another thing that academics, in my experience, aren't always great
at, sharing resources, data, et cetera.
And I'll give you just a couple of examples.
Our very first project was a large PCORI pragmatic trial.
And in that, we brought in about $10 million to the state to help
address tobacco control.
So what the state did was actually take some of the resources
that they were using for tobacco control that we could offset with the
grant and move that money into providing cessation medications
for folks who were uninsured. So it was a
really beautiful synergistic sharing of data, resources.
Similarly, during COVID, we had three RADx
grants from NIH, which are addressing underserved populations.
And we met with the state at least weekly and many times twice a
week because if you'll remember during COVID,
where you could test and who could test changed
literally week by week by week. So we
did whatever we needed to do to address what was going on there, and I'll
actually come back to that a little bit later on.
And then finally, we've provided millions and millions of dollars through our
funding with AUCH and the CHCs to provide
resources to buy a population health management
system, which ties together all the data from all the CHCs
across the state. So it really lets them start to do a
lot more big data,
targeted cohorts across the entire state, across these 14
independent systems. And I should have mentioned that because what's unique
about the CHCs,
they're not a single system. They're not a Kaiser.
They're not one giant large CHC. They can all choose to partner or
not partner with you independently.
So the other thing is
respecting their expertise.These folks are
very dedicated. They've been doing this a long time.
They're getting their hands dirty every day.
So we meet with the leadership at OUCH every few months to find out
what their priorities are. And priorities at CHCs
around the country are driven heavily
by the funding that is available to them on whatever's happening
that year. So you have to be on your toes, reaching out to them
constantly, find out what they care about.
Their priorities are also driven by what are called UDS measures,
which are their national reporting on how well they're doing.
Every quarter, we also meet with a patient advisory group and a studies
advisory group, and the patient advisory group is nothing but
patients. We get everybody else out of the room other than the scientists and
the patients, and they will tell you what they think, and they will be
exceedingly blunt.
They will tell you that they feel judged by their providers if they talk about
alcohol use or tobacco use, so they will just flat out lie.
So it really helps us to get that feedback because we
use that in our training for providers and clinic staff about how to be
non-judgmental in working with these populations.
We also have a studies advisory committee, which includes those patients, but
also representatives from all the organizations we work with.
And we vet lots and lots of stuff with them, and they,
again, have no problem telling us when we're doing something stupid
or have wording that we thought was really brilliant, and they will tell
us that they hate it. So it's really good to have these kinds of
feedback loops because they know their clinic staff and they know their
patients.
We have a weekly meeting that includes multiple projects, includes members of OUCH,
CHCs, et cetera, and that's really getting into the
nitty-gritty of implementing projects.
And then finally,
when we first got there, we did something really unique, and it has been
a spectacular
thing for us. This woman right there,
Tracy Saperas, is an employee of OUCH.
She spent about 10 years working on the front lines in the CHCs, and
when we got our first big grant, we jointly funded her through the Center
for HOPE, through OUCH, and through the State Department of Health and Human
Services. And she provided the link between all of us,
and she has just been instrumental in bringing CHCs on board
because they trust her, and she has no problem telling us when we have crappy
ideas. So we work with her to vet, get good
ideas, and then we can take them to her to tell us
how they're doing, and then to the CHCs, and they fly really well.
And so before COVID, she spent four days a week in our office with us.
After COVID, no one comes to the office anymore.
So, anyway.
The other thing that we learned right off the bat is
community health centers do not want you to
create interventions, implementation strategies,
anything that's going to go away as soon as the grant goes
away. They want only projects that address all their
patients. That includes uninsured.
They only want projects that whatever you implement and
put in place can live on after the grant is over because they don't
want to give it to their patients and then take it away.
So that has led us to really design what we do with
them from the point of view of sustainability after the grant's over.
So that's led to a huge
piece on digital health as really a foundational
piece because all of the CHCs have electronic health
records. They also have now that population health management tool,
which ties everything together. Those tools have
features that we can actually use to reach out to
patients, to optimize clinical workflows, things like
that. So that's really a foundation.
The other thing we do is employ their
staff when we need to do something that involves
people. So for example, if we want to do patient navigation,
we employ their community health workers.
And then finally, we try the best we can
to use existing evidence-based interventions
because, again, we don't want to take it away when the study's over.
So, for example, when we're addressing tobacco use, we partner with the state
quit line because they'll provide free treatment and free
cessation meds. We partner with the state's breast and cervical cancer
program,
with diabetes prevention programs, et cetera.
So we use existing EBIs to work with
them because those things will be there when the grant's over.
So we've been unbelievably successful.
We're now serving over 20 PIs
at Utah and the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
We've got about 55 million in funding in the last nine
years. We're addressing risk factors for cancer
and other chronic disease. We're addressing lots of different cancer screenings,
HPV vaccination. And again, even though I'm at a cancer
center, and I remember my cancer center director once saying, "You need to
spend more time on cancer." Well, if my partners tell me they need to help
with COVID, we did nothing for three years but work on COVID, right?
Because you need to help them and you need to address their priorities.
So we've addressed non-opioid pain management, social needs, COVID, et cetera.
The other thing about our approach to sustainability is that it
really lends itself well to population-level
scaling, meaning taking interventions to the entire
population, not
like a clinical trial where you have a very self-selected sample.
We're doing studies where when we work with these populations, we're
getting 98% of the potentially eligible people
into a study.So for example, our very
first trial, we hoped to enroll 6,000 patients into a
tobacco cessation study. We enrolled 12,000.
Every single tobacco-using patient who came into one of our
10 participating CHCs and their
clinics was enrolled in the study.
During COVID,
we enrolled 107,000 patients
in our very first trial with them, out of a grand
total of 160,000 people that they serve
across the board, and many of them are not eligible.
And again, this is about serving their priorities, because remember, testing
changed every week. Who could get tested changed every week.
Vaccination came out. Who could get vaccinated changed every week.
So we did rapid cycle designs, 37
different message workflows, 227 different
cohorts,
a third of our messaging in Spanish, and we had conversations with
patients via the strategies we used for about a third of the patients.
Our second-- How am I doing?
Okay. Our second COVID trial was at the end of the
pandemic, and it was promoting at-home tests, and we enrolled
33,000 folks in that. So when you're using these
digital health strategies, you're using existing evidence-based
interventions. You can really ramp things up to serve entire
populations instead of very self-selected samples.
And I'm just going to give you one example of impact,
and that is we received funding in 2020 from
the CDC to do colorectal cancer screening.
We've just actually received our second round of funding to do colorectal
cancer screening from the CDC. During our first round of funding,
we increased screening from about 36% to
43%, which might only seem not
like a lot in terms of an absolute difference.
That's almost a 20% increase. And most
importantly, it's hard to increase screening
in FQHC populations because they don't have pathways
to colonoscopies and pathways to treatment.
So our increase actually accounted for almost
half of the national increase in CHC patients
across the nation. So it actually worked
incredibly well. We're exceedingly proud of this.
HRSA's highlighted us in their national conferences.
And so just a few key takeaways. Again, I told you, I think this
stuff is actually pretty simple. Address your
partner priority. It's really, really easy to create a win-win if
they say, "We want help with breast cancer screening," and you work with
them to design a project that would help them do that.
They'll work with you if you do that.
Second, leverage their expertise.
So
much of our communication, of our training,
has been influenced by what they tell us.
They know what flies with their staff and their patients.
Invite all sorts of different partner perspectives.
So for example, on our patient advisory committee, we
have a woman who thought COVID was
completely fabricated. It was a conspiracy theory.
So exactly what we needed to hear because it informed
how we communicated with patients across the state, particularly
rural patients, where this was a more prominent belief.
And then finally, always be looking out for
ways to bring funding in that helps your partners.
And then the other thing is, this is sort of the most second
critical thing behind addressing their priorities, is
never walk away from them, ever. If
your funding runs out, you need to still be somehow in
there working with them, helping them. We call that bridging capacity.
So we never, ever walk away from the partners, because if we walk away
from them and then in a year, NCI releases a center grant that's due
in two months, they're not going to partner with us.
But if we've been in there working with them all the way through that, they're
happy to work with us. So
that's about all I have, and I'm taking questions now.
Right?
We have five minutes.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Happy to take any questions.
Yes.
Can you go to the microphone?
Hi. Great presentation. It's remarkable how you're able
to accrue so many people into your smoking
cessation trial in particular. So I was wondering if you'd tell us a little bit
more about
who did the recruiting for that. Was
it the actual sites? Did they do the informed consent and the data
collection?
And also payment associated with that.
Were people paid for participation? How did you compensate sites?
Yes. Great question. And this is really, really critical.
If you want to do population level research, you need to
design the study in a way that it is
actually sort of promoting standard of care.
So, for example, much of our research here, you'll notice, is actually all about
increasing reach, not efficacy. So if
anyone's had a public health background, there's an equation.
Impact equals reach times efficacy.
We think there's way more opportunity and a bigger bang for your
buck increasing reach than there is efficacy.
I can monkey around with the tobacco cessation intervention and get a couple of
percentage points better maybe than standard of care, but I can get
10 to 20 times more people into the...
existing standard of care by focusing on reach.
When you're doing that, our IRB will let us do what
they call opt-out consents which means that we
send a letter to the patients, communicate with the patients everybody
that's a tobacco user, for example,
and we
tell them they're going to be in a research study.
And if they choose, they can opt out by either
returning a postmarked postcard, by clicking
on a link to get out of it, by responding to a text, by
multiple different ways to get out of it.
When you do that, then you can actually get virtually the
entire population enrolled. In this one,
because we were promoting the state quit line, we didn't even have to do an opt-out
consent. We got a waiver of consent.
So that's how you can reach entire populations.
If you're testing a new intervention, it's
unlikely you'd be able to do this kind of thing.
But when you're testing different strategies to get them in to what
they already want them to be in, we've had a lot of success with
our IRB.
Great question, though, because that's one we get a lot.
Building, and thank you for a wonderful presentation.
Building on that comment,
I'm curious about, you gave this
statistics, 47 or close to 50% uninsured, and
then seeing the remarkable screening for colorectal cancer.
And I was curious about the considerations of, it was a EHR,
digital health intervention. And I was curious about barriers, both
physical and electronic barriers to recruitment for those types of
interventions and your experience addressing that.
Yeah.
And I imagine particularly for uninsured individuals, a lot of their
interaction with the healthcare service would be through emergency services.
So I was curious about your experience there.
Yeah. So
make sure I got your question right.
Again, this is where we use digital health as a foundation.
So in virtually every study, even if we're not testing a
specific electronic health record
intervention or implementation strategy, we help them
optimize their EHR. And none of these
folks
are using Epic or Cerner.
These are folks that are-- There's a joke, and I hope it won't offend anyone,
because when we started work with these EHRs nine years ago, the joke
was, "This looks like it was programmed by a drunk second
grader."
There is no logic. There's no branching.
In Epic, you can do
trapeze acts. You can't do
virtually anything in a lot of the EHRs that community health centers
use because they can't afford to use Epic or Cerner.
So we always try to help optimize to the best that we can, whatever they
have.
But what all those
EHRs almost all have is some kind of text messaging capability.
They also have, and because we now have the
population health management platform, they all have what they call
campaigns, ability to reach out. Because now we can see the whole
set of patient data from across the entire state, and we can reach out to people
who might be eligible for colorectal cancer screening.
So the other thing that's a great way to reach these populations that
are living in poverty, 97%
of individuals living below $30,000 a
year have a cellphone capable of text messaging.
About 65% have smartphones. So if you want to do smartphone stuff,
you're leaving out a third of the population.
But if you want to do something that has a text as the communication
modality, you can reach virtually everybody.
What that enables you to do is still do fancy stuff, though.
We have AI chatbots that can be on the back end, right?
But they're interacting with it through a text messaging capability.
So we're just taking-- Making sure I remember the question.
I've been going a long time. We're using digital health.
We're building things that are going to stay there
long after we're gone because we're building it into their existing
tools. And that lets us be able to reach entire
populations that are eligible for colorectal,
HPV,
tobacco, you name it, lots and lots of different stuff.
Do I need to be wrapping up?
Yeah, you have two minutes.
Okay.
I'll make it quick. It was an amazing talk.
Janine Figueroa from NCI.
The improvement in getting more screening, preventative
services, I think that's fantastic.
But of course, we know that the mortality gap is
still
worse right? For many of our lower
or underserved populations. And so I'm curious,
especially with cancer being such a challenging disease once you're
diagnosed with it,
how are your centers actually managing that challenge?
And hopefully, also trying to get them access to more of the
current treatments. I know you said that we want to go with already existing
routine care, but are there opportunities for us to make sure that they also get
access that other
populations are getting as well?
Yeah. So we're fortunate in Utah. So we've
not addressed survivorship or anything, or get
access to treatment explicitly in our projects.
One of the great things that Huntsman did, probably about six or seven
years ago, is they created a voucher program for
screening.
So for example, half of the people that I just showed you earlier
on, half the people are uninsured.
SoIf we can get someone to a Huntsman
facility, which is really hard in some of the rural
areas. Utah is a big state. 97% of our land
mass is rural or frontier. But if we can get someone to a Huntsman
facility for their screening, we can pay for it with a voucher.
If they're screened at one of our facilities, I'm really
proud we've done this, we will then take responsibility for
their care all the way through,
regardless of whether they're uninsured, living below the poverty level, et
cetera.
Some other states, Montana has a kind of similar thing through the
state, and Rula's giving me that I need to shut up.
So, thank you.
And we'll have time at the end. Thank you.
We'll have time at the end for-
More time?
Yeah.
I'm next or you?
I'm next.
Everybody wants to talk. It's great.
Okay, great. I'm going to talk about our center, which is the Center for
Social Capital, we affectionately call it SoCa:
Promoting Multigenerational Health.
I just want to acknowledge I am really presenting the work on behalf of the center
and really highlighting the work of two of my colleagues here, Dr.
Erica Phillips and Dr. Phoenix Matthews.
This is an initiative across multiple institutions, so Weill
Cornell Medicine, Columbia University, and SUNY Downstate.
So New York City is a really unique, I think, area.
Areas where there are pockets of a lot of wealth, but there's actually very
disparate wealth gaps here. So you have
pockets of very wealthy areas, and you can see here the red
shading is areas of persistent poverty.
So a lot of poverty,
very close to areas of extreme wealth.
And so we chose four particular neighborhoods, really to focus on,
across New York City as part of our SoCa Center.
And the theme for our center was around social capital.
And this really came out of, as David said, talking to members of our
community. And so we had community round tables where
we talked to members of our community to see what was important to them, and
we had specifically asked them what they thought were barriers
to early cancer detection and cancer prevention.
And these were the top three things that they mentioned, financial burden,
low health literacy, and lack of social support, stigma, and
discrimination. And so it was really this third one that we
really pulled in as our theme, thinking we didn't really think that we
would be able to change poverty, but what we thought we could do was try and
influence social capital, and that perhaps by
increasing social capital, that could ameliorate the negative
impacts of poverty on cancer outcomes.
And so social capital for us really encompasses a lot of different things,
social support, social cohesion, trust,
belonging, a number of these things listed here.
SoCa also has another
meaning, so some of you may be familiar with soca music.
It stands for soul of calypso. This is a genre of
Afro-Caribbean music. One of our leaders, Erica Phillips, was so
excited to be able to name a center SoCa.
It really is music that has evolved over time, as a genre
of Afro-Caribbean music that actually brings in influences from
other groups, and one-third of New York City's Black population
are immigrants from the Caribbean.
So it felt very fitting that this was sort of a nod to that, as well as
a vision for our own center, which we hope will also evolve over
time and bring in influences for other communities and
really have a positive impact in the communities that we serve.
So the mission of our center really is to promote and reduce cancer
health inequities in areas of persistent poverty.
I'm going to talk about, very high level, two of our projects.
One is a Cares For You project, and one is called Bridge to Quit.
And I'm going to highlight also, part of this is really cultivating the next
generation, who would be able to continue doing research in this area, and
I'm going to highlight just one of our educational missions.
So back to sort of the framework that we talked about.
The two projects that I'm going to highlight today are the Cares For You and Bridge
to Quit, both of which I think really focus on some of this
institutional context, one focusing on education,
especially among middle schoolers, and the second one focusing on healthcare
systems.
So Cares For You stands for Cancer Risk Education in Schools for Youth and
Families.
And this really came out of, I think there's been a lot of sessions here.
I think we all know that there has been an increase in early onset cancers.
You can see here that the blue line, I guess I can use this.
I don't know if this works. Blue line here is really, cancers among
people under the age of 40 has been increasing over time.
And when we specifically look at New York City and New York State,
you can see New York City is the red bars, and the orange are New York State.
We consistently have higher rates of cancers, especially among
individuals under the age of 40, both in New York City and New York State.
And so really trying to think about how to address cancer
prevention in those age groups. And there have been a lot
of reviews out there, putting out what could be attributable to factors,
everything from obesity and lifestyle changes, to genetics and
hormonal factors, and we really thought that this could be an
opportunity. We know that obesity and lifestyle factors influence
cancers, and early onset cancers, but
this could be an opportunity, really to make sure that we focused on one
area, focused on obesity and
lifestyle.Again, this is a project led
by Dr. Erica Phillips. This was an intervention
to really design a cancer education curriculum
to middle schoolers. So aim one was
co-creating a six-module cancer education
curriculum, training middle school science teachers, this is within the New
York City's public school system, and implementing this
intervention. And the outcomes here are really to impact
and assess if this increased the students' knowledge and
intention to gauge in health-promoting behaviors
for themselves, as well as there's this idea that children
are agents of change. So the information that they learn, they will take home to
their families, to their caretakers, and see if there is
increased communication within the household, and if that does
impact their family members'
intention and knowledge with respect to cancer risk.
And so I think some of the things just to highlight here is that
adolescence is a critical period in the life course to really thinking
about intervening on future cancer risk.
But most of our interventions are really focused mostly on adults
and those who are in later life. And second,
really, I think there are few rigorous studies out there that have really focused
on cancer education, especially in the middle schools, and how that
can impact both knowledge as well as change in
behaviors.
So again, the outcome as this study, the primary outcome was really looking at the
intention to follow health-promoting behaviors.
This is all done doing surveys, really focusing on
nine cancer risk behaviors, so diet, physical activity,
alcohol, smoking, body weight, vaccines, and sun
protection. And then the second aim is really focused on cancer risk
communication, so really to assess if these middle schoolers are talking
about these with the people that they live with.
And then we have an exploratory aim really to see, is this kind of
permeating beyond just the middle schooler to the individuals that they live
with? And that includes a 13-item scale
focusing on cancer knowledge as well as cancer risk
behaviors.
This is what the Cares For You science program looks like.
It covers everything from cancer genetics, cancer epidemiology,
media literacy, nutrition and cancer, biotech and
cancer, and cancer risk reduction.
These were six units with 14 different lessons.
These all aligned with the New York State's next generation
science standards. It included two hands-on
science labs, a field trip to a cancer center,
very important.
There were some real-world STEM professionals,
that they got to learn from. And really trying to also pitch this as
cancer prevention is a social justice campaign, was a
cumulative project that the students worked on.
So this has now been implemented in four middle schools across three
boroughs, over 288 students total.
In this next year, we are expanding this to two additional pilot
schools and three former pilot schools.
We also did a out-of-the-classroom experience called
STEM Day, where students came
to hear how people are using STEM in
their daily lives in terms of professionals.
And you can see there was really
high like
for these things. So 95% of the students said that STEM Day helped them to learn
something new about science, 90% said the speakers were
interesting to listen to, and 85% learned about a job
that they did not know existed before.
And this mural on the bottom here, one of the other things that we did was,
again, sort of this idea of social justice, worked with students that were part of
an art program, talked to them about how
smoking and advertising led to smoking in
specific neighborhoods, and they, as a group, came together to
put together this mural, which is now up
in Brooklyn.
The second project I'm going to talk about is the Bridge to Quit, which is led by
Dr. Phoenix Matthews. Although this is focused on smoking cessation,
I do think that this is really a health systems
intervention because the first aim of this is really to
focus on increasing uptake of the use of patient portals,
in general. And then aim two is really focused on the
smoking cessation. And this project is really looking at an
intervention within federally qualified health centers.
Again,
we know that 30% of cancer deaths in the US are attributable to smoking,
so really using this as an opportunity to link people
to smoking cessation and the New York State
Quitline. We also know that there's higher smoking prevalence in low-income
populations, and this disproportionately impacts racial minorities,
and that there are disparities in access to smoking cessation
resources and support.
And so we really, again, targeted some of the federally qualified health
centers within New York City,
to be able to try and implement this smoking cessation
idea.
So Ask, Advise, and Refer is a
three-minute
way to sort of ask about tobacco use, advise, and refer people
to smoking cessation. We know that traditional referral
methods can be timely. Physicians already have a lack of
time. The best practices advisories really recommend
automated clinical alerts within the electronic health record, but we know that
physicians also are experiencing alert fatigue,
and there are issues with respect to direct outreach in terms of we don't have a
lot of this information within our electronic health
records.So the idea of using patient portals,
we know that patient portals have been increasing over time.
This is data from Hintz showing that since
2014, the number of individuals offered patient portals
has been increasing and as well as the number who actually access a patient
portal. But you can see that even in 2022, the
rates are up to almost 80% being offered and
maybe 70% actually access. And so this is nationwide, and I'm
going to show you data to contrast what's happening in our own neighborhoods.
So we wanted to really, one, address tobacco as a known
driver of premature cancer-related death among communities impacted by
poverty. But to do that, we wanted to address the digital divide
and test these scalable strategies.
So we know that not everyone has access to patient portals, and so this
intervention was really aimed at trying to increase the number of
people who are on patient portals within the
FQHCs.
So we were testing two strategies.
One is a patient navigator support for enrollment into the patient
portals, and the second is a tailored low health literacy educational
campaign. Again, we selected three neighborhoods where we have
persistent poverty in the New York area.
One of these centers
is the control center, and the other two are the intervention centers.
And at the intervention centers, this is both the educational campaign as
well as patient navigator support for enrollment onto the patient portal.
And this is what the workflow looks like. It looks very complicated.
I think the main idea is this was all done with
stakeholder involvement, really understanding how the workflow
worked, what patients preferred.
Starts with a phone call to let them know that they'll be there, really working
with the staff there to identify people in the patient waiting rooms,
finding out if they've accessed the patient portal but are having difficulty.
If they're having difficulty, they help them.
If they've never accessed the patient
portal, they explain more to them about the patient portal to see if they're
interested, and really try to help them to navigate
and enroll in the patient portal.
So you can see this is our pre-implementation.
The rates of enrollment in the patient portals in
these New York City neighborhoods really is around
34% to 44% across these three. So
much lower than what we see from the Hintz survey, which is nationally
representative.
And
after implementation, so this was after about 18 months of
implementation, you can see that at the intervention sites,
now enrollment was 61%. So the goal had been 50%, so
this really exceeded the goals. You can see the pictures here
of these are some of the patient navigators
explaining what the portal has to offer and then actually helping them
to access on their own devices.
For the people that refused, we tried to find out why it was that they may have
refused. About a third of them preferred to
enroll at home, about a quarter of them were not interested or perceived this
as low value,
and about another 20% of them needed either additional
assistance or really had lower tech literacy.
So the next half of this project, we're in year three, the next half of this
project really is going to be able to see, can we now link these people again to
the New York State Quit Line, trying to use the evidence-based
interventions for
smoking cessation.
And as David mentioned, this really couldn't be done without both patient
engagement as well as so many partners here.
I think I did mention the New York City Public Schools, but I did not mention
actually Math for America,
which was really important for the project on education, was
really important when we think about sustainability in terms of expanding
beyond New York and New York City.
Very quickly, I just want to highlight the educational program.
So we do have a Career Enhancement Corps as part of
our project. And one of these, I think oftentimes our
Career Enhancement Corps is focused on pre-doctoral or post-doctoral, and
this is really aimed at providing skills and professional
development for clinical research coordinators with the idea
that insiders of the community are going to be able to have just
a better understanding of what is important to those communities.
They're going to be able to have more trust with the patients that they're going to
be working with.
And they themselves may have reasons for engaging in the work.
And so this is really educational program aimed more at college students
as well as post-baccalaureates to train them into
becoming clinical research coordinators.
And it involves two weeks of didactic training, as well
as some shadowing that happened both at Columbia and Weill Cornell.
And you can see this is the advertisement for what the program looks like.
This is led by Yasmin Carrasco at
Cornell. And we've seen really early
outcomes that suggest the training is improving
self-efficacy in clinical research and clinical trials.
We did pre- and post-assessments.
There's high satisfaction with the didactic component of the program,
100% satisfaction with the shadowing experiences.
And we really are thinking about sustainability, integrating this within our
cancer centers. The educators are part of our cancer centers.
And we're working with human resources to make sure that when they graduate, that
there are opportunities for them to have jobs within our cancer
centers.So key takeaways, I think social
capital is a novel and important way, and could provide an
opportunity to ameliorate the impact of poverty on cancer
risk and outcomes. I think focusing especially on
adolescents and thinking about increasing intergenerational health
literacy is another important, unique factor
of these designs. And then the potential to increase access to care through
the portal enrollment, although this specific project is focused on
smoking cessation, there are so many other opportunities that
could feed after that, beyond that.
The partnerships were extremely important.
We had partnerships with healthcare, community groups, and policymakers.
And then thinking about really training and providing the skills that are needed to
continue and expand this area of research is extremely
important.
And with that, I'm happy to take any questions.
Janine?
Hi, Rula. Great talk. So I'm curious, how are you going
to track, I guess,
the engagement you're having with these communities at the schools,
to see if they either go on to careers in STEM
or we improve the health of those communities?
What kinds of metrics are you guys thinking about following up on in the future?
Really good questions.
For
that particular project, it is all questionnaire-based.
So we are continuing with quick questions throughout to
see before that
module, what was their answers to those questions,
as well as immediately after. And then we're going to do
another survey later. So that is actually just really going to capture, I guess,
knowledge and their intentions and if they kind of maintain those
intentions. But in terms of the career and careers in STEM,
I don't think that there's currently
anything that would be there for tracking that.
But really good question and something to think about.
Yeah.
Great presentation. Congratulations on a lot of-
Thank you
... good outcomes. I have a follow-up question about the coordinator program
that you developed.
Yeah.
What sorts of incentives? It sounds like you recruited primarily
undergraduate students and
along those lines, but did they get credit?
How did you keep them, and what motivated them to want to
participate and commit to this?
Really good question. So we pay for all of it, so there's no sort of
tuition or anything burdensome on them.
We do try to design it so that it is during their breaks,
so either in the winter
or
over the summertime. We have considered also thinking if this
should be an after, sort of a at night kind of program.
So we have tried to be flexible in understanding that some are going to be in their
senior year of college and others are going to be graduated but
could be working. So again, we are trying to find times that really work
for the majority of people. But that's a really good, important
question. Yeah. Thank you.
I'm glad your intervention started with trying to increase patient portal
representation because, without that, you could only
perpetuate disparities.
But did you get to what the hesitation was to enrollment?
Did you do any mixed methods or qualitative work?
I personally did not. Dr. Phoenix Matthews is really
leading that project, and they have done a lot of
focus groups and really working with--
They've done this now in different communities, both in Chicago and New York City,
to really understand what the
barriers are to that. So I'm sorry, I can't really answer that.
Okay. Oh.
Hi. Pam Hull from University of Kentucky.
I have a question about the first one, about the health
behaviors.
So I was wondering, how did they handle...
I know we have an epidemic of obesity, but we also have an epidemic
of eating disorders among females in particular.
How do they sort of balance that? I know there was healthy eating and physical
activity, but there was
a goal for losing weight. So how did they try to balance
or
craft the messaging and information to not-
Right
... encourage that?
I don't know the specifics around it. Dr.
Phillips is a general internal medicine physician who is
focused on obesity, and so I do think that it was more--
My guess is that it's more focused on, as you're saying, healthy eating and
physical activity,
and less focused on weight. And I think, a lot
of what she focuses on herself is also just
thinking about some of the biomarkers that
would demonstrate altered metabolism.
So my guess is there's more about kind of the science and the
mechanisms why,
even though obesity is easy to measure, it's not necessarily the best metric for
both health or for cancer.
Thank you.
Thank you. So we had one of the five
persistent poverty centers, and ours was really very different than the
others. We took a different approach.
We called ours Upstream because we were looking at upstream factors related
to
cancer and to other
factors related to health equity.
So I have no financial disclosures.
So here's our team, and
I just wanted to just talk a little bit about how we structured it.
So the persistent poverty centers
had-had certain
criteria that we were following with two projects.
We had advisory boards just like Dave and Rila were talking
about. Since our center covered the whole Northern
California area, we came together with UCSF and UC
Davis and Stanford, and that was how we put together our center,
is that we all like working together and we wanted to find a
project that would be important to all of us.
So on the Stanford side, it was me and David
Rakoff, who is a social epidemiologist, and we brought David Grusky
in, who's a professor of sociology, and he heads up the Center
for
Poverty at Stanford, and we thought that was an important
addition to our group. Luis Carvajal Carmona is at
UC Davis and has been working, at that time, he
was involved in their community outreach and engagement, but
also involved in the cancer center.
And of course, Bob Hiatt, who many of you know.
We consider him one of the fathers of social determinants of
health. And so we all came together very
happily because we still, and continue to work
together. We had two research projects that I'll talk
about. One of them is a guaranteed basic income, and the
other is also looking at upstream factors related to EITC.
We have a very active
regional coalition that meets regularly to
help guide us with the work that we're doing in the community.
So as you can see, Northern California covers a huge area of
the state and large numbers. And we looked at the persistent
poverty areas that we share in our
communities with the three cancer centers, and you can see
the colors. And we overlap some of our
catchment areas, and that's why we thought it was important for us to work
together on this important
focus that we had. So just to look at the numbers, because
we looked at this too, of we have a really varied
population. I live in Silicon Valley, which is some of the
highest zip codes in the country. And then when we look at some of
the other areas in the Central Valley, they're some of the lowest
poverty areas in the country. So we looked at this by the
three cancer centers and our catchment areas, and you can see with
the Asian population in
our whole Northern California area,
it's about almost
one-third of the population of California.
Same as we look at Africans, Black African-Americans, not
necessarily Latinos, because a large proportion of Latinos live all
across the state. So these were the populations
that were included in all of our catchment areas, and we covered
a lot of
territory.
Let me bring this one. We followed the same conceptual model
that Rila presented at the very beginning, and
all of us have done a similar kind of thing, looking at these
different factors with fundamental causes of cancer,
social context, and social relationships, and then looking at
individual demographic and other factors,
biology, covering the whole gamut of
different factors that are related to cancer.
And that's how we put our center together in the model, using the
Warnecke model and then adapting it.
So the project one is really interesting.
At the time we were submitting this grant, the state of California
was starting a project of guaranteed income,
a pilot in California, and funding this with
about $5 million. It was coming from the state of California.
And so we contacted them when we heard about this, thinking that this would be
a great way to evaluate what
happens when people are given additional income.
This
pilot went to
five different centers. I can't remember exactly how
much money. Each center was
given a certain amount of money to fund people that were
either aging out of foster care or pregnant
women. And so what we wanted to know is how effective
is giving people additional funds affecting health
outcomes. And obviously, these were not cancer, necessarily,
outcomes, but we wanted to look at their lifestyle factors and how they used
their funding to help support healthier lifestyles.
So the guaranteed income program was run through
these different organizations across the state. It wasn't just Northern California.
And then Urban Institute was the
research institute that was evaluating all of these.
So we partnered with them and continue to partner with them because we were able to
ask additional questions that they administered at multiple different
times during this pilot program.
So they funded about 3,000 participants that were
randomized to treatment or control, and they all got money, but some of
them didn't get as much money throughout the
time period that they were given the funding.
And as I mentioned, there were about 2,200
pregnant women and then about 800 foster youth who were covered
during this program. So our interest was in physical health.
Does getting a little bit of additional funding at this time of their life
help them with their physical health, stress and mental health,
finances, unexpected shocks that could come with
problems that arose that they needed to use their funding for?
And then, because we wanted to have a cancer focus, we're
looking at factors related to colon cancer,
looking at diet and other types of factors.
And our hypothesis here was the guaranteed income
reduces stress and promotes healthier behaviors, and that was the outcome of what
we wanted to determine. And
we were also able to look at larger populations
here around the areas where thewhere the guaranteed
basic income program was taking place.
So we're expecting our data soon. We had a call last week with
Urban Institute, and we have not received all of the data
yet, but the participants were surveyed at entry, at baseline,
three months, nine months, and exit, and six months post.
So we're expecting to get our data back soon, and some of the items that
we were looking at was exercise, diet, sleep quality,
outlook, and optimism using the hope index, ability
to
weather unexpected outcomes or shocks such as job loss or
illness.
And so these people pre-registered the analysis plan with
the Open Science Foundation. And so now we're
waiting. We had about 75% response rate, which we thought was really
good, which was in line with the expectations
that we expected. And now we're able
to
look at other safety net programs, whether they were in SNAP,
and other types of programs that they may have
had access to. We're able to match the data as well, and that's
what's taking a little bit of time with the Medicaid
records, with discharge summaries and records, so that we're able to look at their
EHR and their medical records. And we're also able to look at their
employment and earnings through a match that we have through
some of these programs with the IRS and other types of
records. So as we're combining all of the data and matching it, we'll be able
to look at what effect this program could've had upstream
looking at these health effects. The second project that we're
doing
was on earned income tax credit. So when people go to file their taxes and
they have a lower
income, they're offered, but so many people don't take this,
where they get actually real money,
if they're within a certain income tax.
And the threshold increases to about 30,000, and they get
credits through this program. And
it's national. It's not just for people in California.
The EITC is a national program where
people get actually real money back.
We conducted focus groups in a lot of the places where people were
filing their taxes to get some... And our questions that we had to
them were also related to colon cancer screening and trying to
identify how people might use this money for
trying to increase their health behaviors.
So these were the pathways from Cal EITC to colorectal
cancer, just what were we trying to do.
And so we were looking at behavioral changes in populations that were
getting additional funding from their taxes.
And those that received it, looking at income
credits, income effect of their earnings on some of these factors, and
then their employment, looking at health insurance, workplace
programs, and social network to see how these factors could
improve cancer outcomes. We're still just now in
the third year, and we're still assessing some of the effects of
this program.
Each of the programs also had research methods.
And Bob Hiatt was involved in this, and we had
a student, Tanvi Srinivasta. Actually, I said she
had a poster. This was at ASPO. I was one of the few who presented, or the three of
us at ASPO, and I was trying to promote her abstract.
But Bob and his group and others had done something very
similar with colorectal cancer in trying to develop a
risk model to better understand the multifactorial
etiology of both colorectal cancer
in our... Actually, these are national
data. These are data that come from
the literature of trying to develop models related to...
This was to colorectal cancer, but he used a similar model for
breast cancer that was published a couple of years ago.
We're still in the process of finalizing the model to be able
to publish this, but that was one of the ways we were using the
research core for the persistent poverty.
Looking at specific risk factors that were biological, behavioral,
social, and environmental, and trying to incorporate this into, and
perfecting
our model for colorectal cancer.
So of course, as the other, well, Brilla mentioned, is
that career enhancement was also a major part of the persistent
poverty initiatives, and how we could train a new generation of
leaders in medicine and science who will actively promote health
equity and social justice and work to reduce some of the
devastating effects of health disparities.
So each year, we have
funded at each institution,
three
different scholars. And this was just an example of some of the
scholars. And they crossed all different levels.
James Dickerson is a breast medical oncologist, and he was
expanding his research into social determinants of
health. And he was working at genetic testing for
inherited cancer risk in areas of persistent poverty.
Rebecca Mendez is a post-doctoral fellow at UCSF.
So each institution had identified somebody that they wanted
to include. We used our CRTCs. We
collaborated with them to make sure that all of our fellows had additional
training.
And they also
had times to meet with each other for
additional training and collaboration within our own
centers. We have annual meetings, and so they all come and present their
research. And these are just some examples of the work that they've done and some
of their achievements. And so we're really excited about that, is that
grants were submitted.
They've published papers. They've presented at different
conferences and invited talks. And so we're really excited
about the way that we've been able to enhance
the training that our
trainees have received, our scholars.
In addition, we have pilot grants, and so we've now
funded 11 different pilot grants.
All of the
individuals who are funded
meet with our regional coalition before and during to do
bidirectional research and make sure that the research they're doing really
has an impact in the community that we're working in.
You can see the wide variety, and we
identify through a large
process for requesting applications, and we
get a huge number. I
can't remember what we had last year, but I think we had over, what, 45
or something, people from all three institutions
who submitted a proposal. They range from full professors,
Dr. Arden Morris, who's been working in transportation
barriers and colorectal screening, to
pre-doctoral fellows, associate professors.
So they really run the gamut of people interested in this area
of research.So our pilot grant program has been
successful. 50% of our awardees
have submitted research proposals beyond
the pilot grant that they received.
13% have secured additional funding.
63% have disseminated their results at national
meetings or academic forums, and 25% have
resulted in publications and abstracts, and that's just over the last three years.
So I feel like we have been extremely productive.
The other thing we've done is we're trying to bring the group of persistent
poverty centers together. We received
another small award, a
supplement from NCI to develop these real-world
data workshops and bringing people together who are
interested in real-world data and looking at social determinants of
health.
In my department, we run the Center for Population Health
Sciences and have many large data sets, including
SEER-Medicare. We house the American Board of Family
Practices EHR, and we were awarded a
large ARPA-H grant, so we're integrating a lot of
other databases linked to that so that we can expand
the resources that we have. We have MarketScan and
many others. So many of the people are coming together with these
workshops, and we have people from each of the different PPIs
interested in learning more about how to use real-world data, and
we're just starting this program.
Well, we've had one workshop at our first annual meeting, and now
we've expanded it to continue to train people
in real-world data analysis.
We have advisory board members, and they meet with us
on an annual basis, and they're invited to our
annual meeting that we have, and we have regional coalition members,
and they are all very active. In fact, one of them, Isabelle Deron, is on
the NCAP, and she's really active in all of the work we do
and making sure that we're heard and so is the work that we're
doing to the National Cancer Institute.
So anyhow, that's my last talk, and I'm happy to answer
questions.
Thank you for your presentation.
What role does, with any of the
presenters,
politics play in this?
Coming from
a Southern state.
Mm-hmm.
It matters.
Okay. It matters.
It does.
And it matters for us to continue what we're doing, and we might have to
call it something a little bit different, use different words, and as we put
our RPPR
annual reports in, I can tell you that the National Cancer Institute,
our program leaders, have done everything they can to keep our
program going because we think it's important.
So the five centers, and Rula showed you that, one is in Alabama, one is
at MD Anderson
Cancer Center, and Lorna is here. She's one of the leaders.
I saw Lorna put your hand up. Where is she?
She just left.
She just left. So MD Anderson has a persistent poverty
center. We have one in Utah, and Dave is
the PI of New York and California. So those are the five
centers. Politics plays a part in it.
I'm in California, so we are not faced with the same kinds of things
that other states are, but we're continuing the work.
The Alabama group is doing amazing work on the built environment
and other kinds of things, and we just keep doing what we're doing.
We might have to call it something a little bit different, but we are
committed to the work that we're doing.
And as Dave mentioned, we don't leave our communities.
We continue to work with them and stay involved in the people in the
community. This is important to them, and
the politics might play a part, but no one's closing us
down and we're continuing to get funding.
Yeah. I think it plays a
major role in Southern states.
And in the red states, people will vote
against things
if it doesn't go along with the general idea of their
politics. And we
have to constantly deal with
stuff, matters like that. So it makes it really difficult.
I know the people, I know Mona, and I know Maria.
Mm-hmm.
And we've worked together over the years, but it still is
very devastating because the politics
cause a lot of the problems that we see and the poverty that we
see in the Southern regions.
Mm-hmm.
And it's a bigger battle
if you're in the midst of it.
Well,
when we were just at the ASPO meeting,
I think poverty is still an issue that we can deal with and
in ways that we hope can maybe understand
some of these factors, but we know what causes it.
It's all about money when we think it doesn't, and that's why we took a different
approach with upstream and looking at the factors that if you do
help provide additional funds, does that improve people's
lives?
Okay.
But I totally agree with you. Do you have any thoughts about that?
Say that again now.
I was wondering, how do you propose we overcome the politics of what's
going on?
We keep on going, right?
You keep going, but
when you deal with people who will
vote against
something just
because
itIt
doesn't matter
if it would help the majority of people,
they will go against it. So
even the Affordable Care Act,
if it's called Obamacare
they have people who will say, "No, no, I'm against that." But they want
to keep Affordable Care Act.
That's hard to overcome.
Mm-hmm.
And it's something that in the South we fight against.
But you
need the backing of a state to push for the same
kind of benefits
for all. And if you don't have that, just makes it
a difficult task.
I totally agree. And being in California is a lot different for me than
being in Texas, where I was prior to being in California.
I think David had a-
Oh, David has a comment.
Can we have the mic on the... Yep, got it. Okay.
I was just going to say, it is not only in the South.
Utah, the people of Utah voted to expand
Medicaid, and our legislature just gutted it.
And you saw our uninsurance rates of 45%.
Though a lot of the Mountain West states are
just as red,
including, I grew up in Idaho, so we're battling
with other states. I've got to shut
up at this point. So,
yeah.
I had a different question, but to comment on this, it seems that
you were able to establish partnerships with other states and bring them in
to partake in some of these programs. Is that right?
Like you mentioned, you have centers in Alabama and elsewhere
that were able to join as part of this initiative, or-
Well, the NCI funded five centers.
Oh, okay.
Okay? So these are the five centers.
Dave has one in
Utah. Rilla has the one in New York. I have the one in California.
MD Anderson has one in Alabama. So those were the five
centers that were funded. And
one of the goals is for us to be able to work more closely together,
and which we're trying to do because we hope that there will be a second round of
these initiatives, that we could continue some of the work that we're doing.
It might take a different shape, but we're hoping that through the
funding, that we can continue some of this.
Awesome. Okay, so my question was in regard to the guaranteed
income pilot program. In the corner, there was
randomization. You had a control group and the intervention group.
Can you tell me a little bit more about what that control group looked like?
Because did you tell people, "Oh, you might be randomized to this arm where
you'll get this extra funding."
I didn't run that part of the program. It was run by the state.
Oh, okay.
And the groups that they funded to be able to identify people,
but everybody got money. Some of them got a little less than the others.
So that was the randomization. But then as we start pulling together the
data, we will have more of the
data linked with the communities because we'll have
other publicly available data that we can look at for those who didn't.
So we have those that received a little bit more money over the time, those
that received a little bit less. Some of them were
pregnant mothers, some of them were people who were
aging out of foster
care. So we're able to look at the different types, and then also look
at area data, as well from where they lived-
Okay
... in the communities.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Then my other question was for Dave.
You commented on vouchers.
Mm-hmm.
And I wanted to follow up. I was late to the talk because I came from somewhere
else, but can you talk a little bit more about what those were?
Is that transportation or is it a voucher for the actual diagnostic?
It's a
voucher for the actual screening.
Okay.
Our major healthcare system in Utah has a
voucher for diagnostic screening, not for
preventive screening. So that's a problem, because we can't send
people to them because we're doing preventive screenings.
We bugged Huntsman, and they really came through.
It's probably been about five or six years ago, where we'll provide vouchers
for preventive screenings for
colorectal, cervical, lung.
Am I missing breast?
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Thanks.
Right there.
No, I'll take it. Yes. I'll take all the help I can get.
Question?
Yeah. Hi.
Great talk. I was a little late as well because I was coming from somewhere else
again. But I noticed
in your talk, Melissa, a lot of the pilots were focused
on measuring specific upstream outcomes.
But I wonder what is, and if you've thought about it just yet, the
information dissemination plan, because I just imagine that
some of the information, the results that you're going to get are going to be
astounding. So what is the plan for
communicating that in a way that not
only benefits the people so that they understand, but
that that information does get to the right people so
we can hopefully inform some-
Excellent question. So I'll answer that in a couple of ways.
Number one, we have a really strong regional coalition of community
members and community groups. And before everybody
even gets their funding, we ask them to talk to
a lot of the community advisory board
about their project because we want to make sure
thatThat they appreciate what they're doing,
and also to help them as they write it, so we give them that opportunity.
And then afterwards, they come back with the results so that we
can make sure that this is communicated back to the populations that
are important. The other thing we're doing with the upstream,
all of our members is, and for the research communities,
we've compiled about 15 plus, maybe up to
20 papers that will result from the work that we're doing.
And from all of the different aspects, including community
engagement, the results of
some of the projects that we're doing, the
cross-center
initiatives and things like that.
So we will be communicating to the scientific community, but we work
really closely with a lot of community groups and our regional
coalition. And they meet, I think they meet monthly, because I've been
to some of the meetings. And so we have our
recipients who've received grants come, and then at the annual meeting, we
also have that, and then we'll talk about how to disseminate that
information that they've
found from their studies.
Electra.
Hello. Great job. I think you guys are just doing fabulous
work, and I think it's really important to go the upstream and
use these innovative strategies.
So I just want to respond to
Timothy's comments a little bit.
The first is, I think words matter.
And we have to really be creative with the words we use.
We have to keep doing what we're doing.
We can't stop, but we just have to choose our words
and think of different ones.
And so,
I think, for example, we need to come up with a new word for vaccinations and
vaccines, so.
Yes.
That's the latest challenge.
What are you going to call them? Did you-
We're working on that, okay? I got Sarin to help me.
She's the great advocate and, so anyway, we got to
think of a new word. The second thing is, if any of you went to the
policy workshop yesterday, John Rasoff, from
AACR, presented some really interesting survey results.
So AACR commissioned a survey nationwide, and
people responded that overwhelming
majority said they would vote
for legislators, national and state, who
wanted to do things to end
cancer. Like if they were working to
end cancer, positive toward cancer, and they would not
vote for somebody who did not
support cancer research.
So the people in this country are
supporting what we want to do.
There's a disconnect. I think, Dave, you get the great example.
The people wanted it, and this is what the legislature do.
So somehow we, the people,
have to get the legislators to start listening to us
a little more,
and use the power of the polls,
to really walk with what we want because the
people want cancer research. They want it.
Across the continuum.
Across the continuum, and especially to prevent
cancer.
Mm-hmm.
And, they're so excited. You all work with the
communities. They're, A, so excited when you come to help
them, right? So excited when you listen to them,
and so excited when you stay and you don't helicopter in and
out. And that will
promote the positivity that we see about
cancer research and cancer researchers.
So don't listen to the false news that people don't trust
us, don't want us. They really do. They really do.
Thank you. That's a really good point, and I think what's
so important is, as we train our young junior
students and others, that they learn about bi-directional
research. And we have a T32, and one of the things that is really
critical, at least for me, is that our
students work with the community and do things in the community to
understand how to translate, how to communicate the research they're
doing. It's not just to do research and not
include
people who are affected by it.
Shannon?
Yeah. I just want to say this is a really important conversation, and just to build
off of what Electra was saying, and then what you just mentioned about training,
the importance of being involved in the community.
They want us involved, training our young
investigators. I'm wondering, the training programs that
were talked about here a lot focus on undergraduate
training or training at the graduate level.
What about thinking about training in the community?
Could some of these research coordinator positions be
something that we train high school graduates from the community
in to engage them more, to get them employed, involved in
research? So think about training before.
Right. And we're doing that at Stanford, believe it or not.
And we have, as part of our CTSA and others who have
CTSAs, there's a really good opportunity through
that, is to train
scientists.
Or I shouldn't say that. To train the community health
workers and train
advocates of how to understand science so that they could help
communicate it also better. So we've been doing a lot of that, and
there are programs, you have one on community health workers that you mentioned,
and so I think it goes all the way up and down from
students, young kids, to all the way up to community health
workers and
advocates to learn aboutHow to communicate research and working with
the community too. Thank you for that question.
It's really important.
Hello. So great to see all this work.
So my question is about, so we have, say, takeaways for how do we build
partnerships. The question is about how things get started.
Do we reach out to community partners?
Do they reach out to us about, are there funding opportunities or things?
Dave, why don't you answer that? I can answer it.
Sure.
I'm going to brag about us a little bit because we
hosted all the cancer centers around the country for a big
tobacco cessation thing with about 63
centers. I
came from MD Anderson, and one of
my colleagues came with me, and we went and met with the
state. We went and met with OUCH. We
went and met with the community health centers.
And
at this big conference, one of the audience members
asked our partner from OUCH,
asking her how she
created this great partnership.
And she said, "Oh, we've had tons and
tons of researchers come to meet with us.
Dave and Cho are the only two who kept coming back."
So you just
go meet with them, you find out their priorities, and you keep going
back. I
had
some advice from, if you all know Dr.
Jeff Henderson who is a Native American physician, works with Native
American communities, and he says, "If you're going to work with those communities,
you'd better plan on being there all the time."
So we just are there
all the time.
Are you at a cancer center?
I'm actually a student at Weill Cornell.
Oh, well, here's one of your students.
They have, I'm sure, a community-engaged research program at their
cancer center, and I would suggest... Is she one of your students, Prerana?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes. Thank you.
You can do the training.
Yep.
Thank you.
This will be our last question.
Yeah.
I know we're out of time, so this is super quick.
First of all, this is amazing presentation. You're doing amazing work.
And I just wanted to make a comment that 26 years ago,
I started the American Cancer Society Quitline.
And so to see this stuff in action and
proliferated and all these things is just amazing.
So kudos for all the work, but you have a special place in my heart.
Aw.
I worked with the American Cancer Society Quitline 100 years ago.
Yes.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, thank you everyone. That ends our session. So thank you.